Das ist wirklich ein Riesen-Schritt für die
Wissenschaft.
Ein Hubschrauber hätte auf dem Mars ganz
andere Möglichkeiten der Erkundung!
Neue Erkenntnisse könnten uns tatsächlich
im Wochentakt zufliegen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Er könnte vielleicht das erste menschengemachte
Fluggerät auf einem fremden Planeten werden!
Ein kleiner autonomer Mars-Hubschrauber der
NASA, der schon im kommenden Jahr mit dem
nächsten Mars-Rover zum Roten Planeten aufbrechen
soll.
Und die ersten Flugtests waren jetzt tatsächlich
erfolgreich: Der Mini-Helikopter hat bewiesen,
dass er auch in der dünnen Atmosphäre des
Mars abheben und fliegen kann.
Er wiegt nur 1,8 kg und liefert mit unglaublichen
3.000 Umdrehungen pro Minute wirklich ab!
Denn damit schafft der Mars-Hubschrauber der
NASA fast zehnmal so viele Umdrehungen wie
ein gewöhnlicher Hubschrauber… Zu seiner
hohen Leistung kommen noch die gegenläufig
rotierenden Rotoren.
Das alles soll dann Flüge auf dem Mars ermöglichen
und das unter den dort gegebenen Bedingungen,
die wirklich nicht ohne sind!
Konkret meine ich damit z.B. die dünne Atmosphäre,
deren Dichte nur etwa ein Prozent der Erdatmosphäre
entspricht.
Diese galt es also für den Flugtest auf der
Erde nachzustellen: eine gar nicht so einfache
Aufgabe für das NASA-Forschungsteam.
Dazu die Projektmanagerin Mimi Aung: “Um
diese Bedingungen auf der Erde zu bekommen,
müsste man einen Testflug in 30 Kilometern
Höhe durchführen.“
Doch dies würde ein gewöhnlicher Hubschrauber
nicht packen.
Denn laut der NASA-Experten liegt der Höhenrekord
eines Hubschraubers, der hier auf der Erde
fliegt, bei rund 12 Kilometern (40.000 Fuß).
Und so haben die Experten und Expertinnen
für den Flugtest eine etwa acht Meter große
Vakuumkammer entwickelt und darin eine Art
Mars-Atmosphäre erzeugt.
Dafür wurde zunächst die komplette Luft
herausgepumpt und dann Kohlendioxid hinzugefügt.
Und zwar so viel, wie es eben der Zusammensetzung
der Marsatmosphäre entspricht.
Doch das war nur eine der vielen Herausforderungen
für die NASA-Fachleute.
Dazu Teddy Tzanetos „Um das Fliegen auf
dem Mars realistisch zu simulieren, müssen
wir auch zwei Drittel der Erdschwerkraft entfernen.“
Die Lösung dazu war ein wirklich spezielles
Aufhängesystem.
Es hatte die Aufgabe, einen Teil der Last
mitzutragen - und zwar den Flugbewegungen
des Hubschraubers folgend.
So konnte das NASA-Forschungsteam genau analysieren,
wie viel Auftrieb notwendig ist, damit der
Hubschrauber auf dem Mars abheben kann.
Und tatsächlich: Der Testflug war erfolgreich.
Insgesamt zwei Mal hob er in der Vakuum-Kammer
ab und schwebte einige Zentimeter über dem
Boden.
Ein entscheidender Schritt!
Denn nur durch diese erfolgreich absolvierten
Testflüge konnten die Fachleute ihre Modelle
und vorherigen Tests bestätigen.
Dazu die NASA: “Wir brauchten nur diese
fünf Zentimeter Höhe, um alle nötigen Daten
zu sammeln.
Sie bestätigen, dass unser Mars-Helikopter
autonom in einer Mars-Atmosphäre fliegen
kann.
Es war ein großartiger erster Flug.“
Und seine Premiere auf dem Mars wird wahrscheinlich
schon sehr bald folgen.
Denn der Helikopter soll schon im kommenden
Jahr zu seiner Reise zum Mars aufbrechen.
Und zwar als Teil der geplanten “Mission
Mars 2020” der NASA.
Hier soll ein Rover zum Roten Planeten gebracht
werden, der mit “Curiosity” vergleichbar
ist.
Der 2020-Rover wird nicht nur geologische
Untersuchungen des Mars-Boden vornehmen und
den Roten Planeten auf seine Bewohnbarkeit
für eine zukünftige menschliche Besiedlung
untersuchen, sondern auch Ausschau nach Leben
auf dem Mars halten.
Planmäßig soll der Mars-Helikopter im Februar
2021 auf dem Roten Planeten landen - und zwar
gut geschützt am Bauch des Mars-Rovers.
Sein erster Flug ist einige Monate später
geplant.
Und das wird dann wohl eine Premiere werden,
denn bisher waren immer nur fahrende oder
stationäre Systeme an der Erkundung des Mars’
beteiligt.
Zunächst soll er nur kurze Flüge absolvieren,
mit einer Dauer von jeweils 90 Sekunden.
Damit könnte er einige hundert Meter weit
kommen.
Doch die NASA denkt schon an größere Modelle,
die dann folgen könnten.
Denn klar ist, dass diese Vogelperspektive
weitere spannende Erkenntnisse liefern könnte.
Dazu NASA-Mitarbeiter Thomas Zurbuchen: “Die
Fähigkeit, zu sehen was hinter dem nächsten
Hügel liegt, ist für künftige Marsforscher
entscheidend“.
Denn so könnten Hubschrauber als eine Art
Späher auf fremden Planeten unterwegs sein.
Und natürlich auch Orte anfliegen, die von
Landfahrzeugen nicht erreicht werden!
Um den Bedingungen auf dem Mars zu trotzen,
tüftelt die NASA übrigens schon seit Sommer
2013 an diesem Projekt.
So verfügt der Mini-Hubschrauber auch über
Solarzellen, um seine Batterien zu laden und
zudem auch über einen Heiz-Mechanismus.
Schließlich wird es in den kalten Mars-Nächten
wirklich bitter-kalt - kälter als im sibirischen
Winter.
An den Polen betragen die Temperaturen sogar
bis zu minus 120 Grad Celsius.
Weil die Funksignale von der Erde zum Mars
mehrere Minuten unterwegs sein werden, kann
er nicht direkt gesteuert werden.
Somit ist er autonom und lenkt seine Flugbahn
selbst.
Er interpretiert die Befehle von der Bodenstation
und richtet seine Flugbahn danach aus.
Wahnsinn!
Das kann wirklich die Marsforschung entscheidend
nach vorne treiben.
Finden wir dort Leben?
oder Leben wir bald auf dem Mars?
Draufklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatsont
abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!